MARING THEIR SEARCH,UG8tTHE FBD
NONCLASSIFIE1
NDTOP SECRET TO DISCUSARTH
ICALLITRFOHOMELAND S AISO VICE
PRESIDD STEPHANIE MER WHITHOMMIC
CHIEUMU N.
WHY DO YOU THINK T FT  THAT'THE
STION.
K DOS ANGATION, WITHOUREAL'S IN
HE HISMOTIVA
ONTO HELP HIS FUTURE POLITICAL S
UNKNOWGL THEM BACK OVER AND THE
NO MOTIVE ORIN.
BUT I TH REALLY - AMERIC
SEN THE WRONG RE
HAS
IKELIESWSSAH JUSD,
ESPECILY WHEN SEONSEEMINT
RANDOM PRESS
ATT WHY IT'S
THERE? IT THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
SYSTEM WAS.
IT WAS JUST BOXES OFRAND PTOGET.
WHEN I T PICTURE,
I SATHE SHEER VOLUME OF
CLASSIFIED MER
WE'RE HEARING SOME COULDE  HOW
THOSE BOXES AND NO SEEICED.HT IA
SOME HE IN TO BE
WNS
AND THE FA ASKED OR ANERYEAR.
I THING SSAH ALSO SAID
'S DOLLAR QUESTIAT
OLI YKED WITH ED INFORMATION A.
INTHK WOULHAOUENTST WE NOW
MAR-A-LAG
>> I W JAIL.
HONESTLY, EVHEING ESTIONS AFTER.
FIED INFORMA
OR, A RESPBITHAT,
IN AND
THAT IS HORIOUSLY WE TAKE
THE CASE, ANYONOUT.SAPE MUCH L
DOWN THERE.
SSI WANTOUO
ABOUT -- HSA FORMER ATTORNEY GEL
, BILL BARR,
AND WHATE SAID ABOUT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
, AWAY FROM THSHOULDAVD BEEN
. CLASSIFIED.
I THINK M
ING WAS, YOU CLASSIFIED INFORMA
WELL'SUNPRECEDENTED
R IDENT TO TAK
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND N
OKAY W BILBARR'S ALSO -->> FULL.
SOLUTELYIGHT.
SE O
I BELIEVE, HELD A SECURITY
THC PROTOCOLSE
IF YOU PHYSICALLY TAKEM OUT  BUA
CANVA
X-RAYS.
HE HAS THEM CO-LOCEDHIIM
Y CLUB IN FL
R
THERE IS NO WAATHI
PTABLE IF YOU DON'T BEEVD ST
JUSTICE WHERE RMERIS ABOVE THE ,
TRUMP RALLIELAST N AND IT DESCEA
Y N.ONE
MYLF
INVESTIGATED WAS MHA
CLASSIFIED INFORMA, EXTLUMIS IN
SAAS ALL O
THIS MATERIAL, BUT TY'T ING THA.
THEY'VHAT GUESTS
HAD ACCESS TO ERE MAON
DANGEROUSLY  KL IN HIS HOME WAS.
YO
COMMUNICATIONSTOR.
K THIS IS  NOTY A
OH,
I MEAN, THERE'S FITRACKS GOING
FOR DONALD TRUMP, IT'S
AND, YOU KNOW, I NLLLA
BUT FROM THE CLIPS I,
RIGHTIDN HIS TRUTH S LIALLY HAY
SOCIHAMENTS WERE
ON THEOR AS.SO, HE HASE
I WOULD IMAGINE WE'RE GOING TO
SEE A ERHE
L HE'S HIS VOICECOINNDLA
NOT  RESPONSIBITINK THAT HE DOE
ANIGHT WING
SA T. YPARTY WILL BELIE
I THE HYISE ISHING TO WATCH.
I WANT TO TURN
BIS SPEE THIS WEEKID AND WHOLESE
UM THECANS.
REPUBCAE WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMID THAT WHAT YOU'VE ALL BEE
SAYING F ATIME N. T
YO
A LIFE LONG REPUBLICAN VOTERTIFT
WING O
FOM
SEEN THE LUPO JANUARY 6t
LEADS I WISH T RUNNGET
CANDID RESPONSIBLE
CANDES
REPUBLICAN
INSTEAD OF WHAT THIS IS, WHICH
IS
>> MY ONERN I WOULY --
LIA.I THINK  THINKHE THREAACY I
IMPORTANT ISESR
EPPING